alors comme votre fille vous dites que
c'est un coup de gueule on va vous faire
une interview dernier qu on ne bouge pas
dans le vignoble bien alors dernier coup
de gueule
le dernier coup de gueule que j'ai
poussé c'était hier
contre qui bah c'était à propos de la
sphère rezala d'accord dernier coup de
tête
dernier coup tête qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un coup de tête c'est un truc une
décision qu'on prend comme ça comme
cannes il veut rentrer avec et masque
pas un club comme les maquis ventre avec
kad bon dernier coup de tête c'était il
ya il ya quinze jours quand j'ai acheté
à ma fille des doubles rideaux un sac
voyant venir chez moi et on retourne à
ma fille n'est pas sage est passé trop
salée pour séduire une clientèle folle
non elle voulait un sac voilà une
boutique avec elle elle a 11 ans 1
et elle me dit papa ce sac me plaît et
coûter cher ça marche ça m'a fait chier
de dépenser une somme attentes pour
livrer son sac mais j'ai pas pu lui
refuser celle là bas c'est bien ça part
d'un bon sentiment
dernier coup de poing dans les coups de
poing ouais c'était un vrai quoi stocker
vengeance pas le dire pourquoi dans ce
quelqu'un qui a fait une réflexion des
images
il est nécessaire mais il dépend des
fois un petit moment en prison
dernier coup de pub dernier coup de pub
ceci ce soir et merci parce que ça vaut
vraiment la peine de dernier coup de
foudre dans les coups de foudre
oui de foudre ces skins ou ma famille
ils ont récemment c'est vrai moi vous
êtes marrant quand même en plus moi
c'est ma femme pour ses 2100 mec moi
c'est ma femme dernier coup de bluff
dernier coup de bluff tous les jours ce
mardi après midi
à vrai dire à à l'audience est à
l'audience fred tabary c'est votre
boulot en même temps mon boulot voilà
dernier coup de barre bat tous les jours
ouais c'est vrai dernier coup de rein
pour finir hier soir bravo
à